it's a great pleasure today to welcome
back an old friend professor Brian
Kernighan now of Princeton University
previous live Bell Labs for those of you
would like to know how we met in the
first instance we have already prepared
a computer file video on this very topic
you can refer to the great - OH -
jailbreak which is all about
computerized typesetting in the very
early 1980s so welcome back Brian it's
only been 30 odd years since you last
spoke to us here and we're delighted to
have you here in the more intimate
computerphile context perhaps I could
begin by asking you just a little bit
about what was it like to work at Bell
Labs right so first let me say it's
actually a pleasure to be back at
Nottingham and this is not the same digs
as you had 30 years ago so it's a
definitely fun to be back what was it
like a Bell Labs well I first went to
Bell Labs I think in 1967 I had I was at
the time a graduate student in computer
science except it was before computer
science it was Electrical Engineering at
Princeton and I was lucky enough to get
a summer job at Bell Labs and so I spent
two summers there actually working on a
couple of different things one of which
became my thesis but it was a wonderful
place because there were an enormous
number of really good people doing
really interesting things and nobody
telling you what to do that's kind of a
rewarding environment and so it was so
good that when I graduated from
Princeton
I didn't even interview any other place
I just said ok I'll go to Bell Labs they
offered me a job why not do it and that
was a decision that was extremely lucky
and I've never regretted it oh yeah what
it was like was I would guess that in
one single largest building there were
probably 4,000 people of whom about
2,000 were probably PhDs in various
forms of science physics chemistry
materials and then on the call of the
softer and mathematics and the
relatively new field of computer science
at that point large number of really
really excellent people and the
environment was you can do anything you
want
because the revenue source for Bell Labs
was very stable it was part of AT&T
which in effect provided telephone
service for the whole country and the
way it did at that time AT&T was a
regulated monopoly which meant that they
had in effect a guaranteed rate of
return and they peeled a tiny piece of
that off for research to improve
telephone service in the country that
was the quid pro quo and because of that
there was no shortage of resources and
no management direction that said you
have to do something that will save the
company and the next quarter that was
really very satisfying and so most
people worked on things that were in
some way long term or at least whose
immediate application wasn't obvious
hard to beat that environment I think of
and I think I was there for over thirty
years and I was never once told what I
should be working on the way it worked
is at the end of each year you had to
write down on one side one piece of
paper what you had done during the year
and they used that to determine how much
they'd pay you next year okay yeah so I
you know I'm all in favor of this
benevolent monopoly environment because
after all he gave his eunuchs and as we
all know eunuchs changed everything it
really really did in the computer
science field but one of the recurring
themes of all your work over the years
was if you like little languages and
software tools in the - OH - jailbreak
movie I think I referred to your pick
you know a little preprocessor for doing
line diagrams within types of documents
but that's by no means the only one so
again was this just you or was there a
lot of mutual interest in the little
language is things joined together with
UNIX pipelines that sort of approach I
think that the interest was perhaps
latent there and then when the pipeline
mechanism was invented which was some
combination of Doug McIlroy with an idea
and Ken Thompson with an implementation
when that came along people started to
think I more consciously of how you
could combine programs so that this
program could do something and produce
output that went to this program and the
combination would do some
richer and more interesting I think it's
hard to in particular that showed up in
some of the document preparation tools
fairly early on because among other
things there were limits on how big a
program could be this was hard to think
back that far but a big machine at the
time would have 64 K bytes and K bytes
by the way not an bytes or G bytes and
so that meant that any individual
program could not actually be very big
and so there was a natural tendency to
write small programs and then the pipe
mechanism basically input output
redirection made it possible to link one
program to another and certainly for the
work that Lorinda cherian I did on eqn
which was a language for typesetting
mathematical expressions the existing
formatting program tear off sort of the
precursor of things like tech today that
was already a big program by the
standards at the time it just barely fit
in the memory for user programs and so
adding more to it was not feasible you
couldn't actually do it and so what we
did instead was to create an entirely
separate program connect them with a
pipeline and then if the program is
going to be separate you can have it
represent recognize a different language
it doesn't have to actually do the same
language because it's a separate program
and I think that that was a place where
perhaps necessity was the mother of
invention that it actually worked out
quite well and then further document
preparation programs you mentioned pick
a moment ago further document
preparation programs had that same
property that up they were separate
programs separate languages tailored to
the particular job that they were trying
to do and so that separation of concerns
worked out really well
forced on us in some ways by not having
very much in the way of computing
resources so although it's postponed you
was a great sense of surprise about wow
you actually gained power and
flexibility doing it this way
yeah and I think people started to think
I know I remember fairly clearly at this
point that when the pipe mechanism was
first invented and it was literally not
more than a day or so of existence in
some sense people started to say hey
wait a minute this is very easy we can
connect programs together but we may
have to change the way that programs are
implemented in a trivial way so that
they read from their standard input
guaranteed they write to their standard
output guaranteed and then you can glue
them together and there was this burst
of making straightforward changes to the
program so that they would fit in
pipelines and then people doing
interesting pipelines with them in
inventing crazy combinations that did
things one of the finest examples was
one that Steve Johnson did for finding
spelling mistakes potential spelling
mistakes in a document you take a
document you convert it into words
that's one program you sort the words
that's another program you compare them
against the dictionary that's another
program and you print the ones that are
in the document but not in the
dictionary and that's another program
and so this multi element pipeline was I
first caught at a spelling mistake
detection program yeah I suppose the
thing you also have to learn as I found
my cost by experience is you've got to
be somewhat careful when a thing has to
be in a pipeline but has to be
transparent you know when you've all
always got to think about how like what
I'm sending down the line fouled up by
being picked up too early by something
that I didn't expect but there again
small price to pay but there's a there's
a nice example of that in sorting if you
think about it as if you have a sort
program in the middle of a pipeline it's
a full stop because it can't the
downstream programs can't do anything
else until the start program has done
its job because it has to see all the
input before it can sort but the fact
that it's a full stop doesn't matter to
the user it looks like it's just a
continuous process and so the packaging
of that is actually quite important to
do it well I think when I first came to
UNIX I was pretty familiar with the idea
of what used to be call the job control
of return so there was no great surprise
in encountering the UNIX shell but again
by the time we're talking about late
version six UNIX version seven late
seventies early 80s all of a sudden it
was as if from nowhere
you've got the idea of other flexible
interpreted languages and I'm thinking
of course primarily of all so how did
that come about right so I think part of
it you mentioned the shells I think part
of it comes about because the shells
were used to combine programs and you
could do other things with the data as
it was passing through in a very simple
way but the shells were not very good
programming languages and so you wanted
to do more with them aughh itself had
three or four different inspirations I
think one of them not as well advertised
at this point I guess was a language
done by Mark Rock and which he had
designed a language for validating data
that was came from telephone switchings
systems or something like that where all
it did was to look for patterns of input
and when it saw a line that matched one
of those patterns it printed it because
it was died or perhaps didn't match it
it was some kind of error and it printed
it so it was in effect a very simple
streaming program so that would be one
influenced from the outside and I had
been interested in somehow having a
programming tool some kind of tool where
I could manipulate text and numbers more
or less together kind of equally easily
see programs were good at numbers but
very bad at text and there and the shell
wasn't really very good at text and
terrible at numbers so I was kind of
interested in that sort of thing Alejo
who was in the office next to me I was
very interested in regular expression
technology he had just finished egress
extended version of grep had much richer
set of regular expressions and very
efficient implementation and Peter
Weinberger who was on the other side of
Al was very interested in database
related things he had just finished
doing a tiny relational database for
UNIX so here's this combination of three
people write together
interested in things that sort of lose
we are related to each other but not
much and so we started talking about
what what do you want what could we do
what could we build here that would be
an interesting tool and then some weird
way is a generalization of CREP and said
it includes a much richer set of regular
expression and stuff and there's this
database flavor Peter knew about RPG the
report generators thing and so the I
don't where you call it the great
combination or the mishmash of these
things put together led us to designing
awk and then doing the first
implementation wasn't a great deal of
work I think at this point my memory is
right Peter did the first implementation
of it over a weekend server three or
four days at most a lot of it was easy
because we had the right tools at hand
in particular we had yak which was the
parser generator that Steve Johnson and
L hey-ho built that made it easy to
define the syntax of a language so that
you could parse statements in that
language and then you could hang
semantic actions on it and that
existence of yak led to a whole bunch of
different interesting tools in the UNIX
environment eqn which we talked about a
few moments ago was done with yak for
example pic which you mentioned done
with yak so it was a very very effective
tool for building new languages and so
that's another reason why I think people
thought in terms of language and I have
a tool it makes it easy to build
languages so let me just do it my
memories of a feeling of the liberation
of setting up a sad and all pipeline
driven from the shell I just thought it
was absolutely great and yet the scene
out in the big wide world although
there's a lot of admiration for the work
he did that some people felt that the
integration might be a positive
advantage I'm thinking of course a pearl
and what's your take on this sort of
trade off if you like between having
everything integrated so that all the
communication between what's happening
is
internal and therefore perhaps more
efficient in quotes I don't know versus
doing it the pipeline way I think it's a
trade-off
I think it's precisely a trade-off that
there's no single right answer it
depends on the application there's some
things for which as a quick and dirty
sequence of separate programs works
really well you just do it you're done
you don't have to think about it if
you're doing something more complicated
perhaps something which is going to last
longer then integrating it into a single
program is probably a better choice but
I without looking at a particular
situation I don't think I would know
which one to use Perl was definitely
built as a reaction to awk awk had a lot
of limitations at the time and some of
the limitations were artificial because
the version that we were using
internally was not the version that was
available outside 80 and its wisdom
decided that they wouldn't release the
richer version and so some of what Larry
wall did would have been obviated by a
newer version of our but then of course
he added enormous number of other very
useful features to it and made it a much
richer scripting language and one which
you could build bigger programs I think
one of the issues for all of these is
how big is the ultimate program going to
be or even the one that you're building
right away if you're doing something
that's only a couple of lines long awk
is great and it really is I don't think
anything beats it for one-liners and
where one is a metaphor for two or three
but when you get bigger than that it
doesn't scale very well because it
doesn't have any of the things that
prevent you from doing something stupid
or at least finding out when you did and
so for bigger programs you want
something that has more going for it and
I think what's going on in modern
programming languages is more and more
of that kind of yeah I think I see a
little bit of that what I loved about of
course was this pattern matching a bit
and then match from that pattern you
took that action but again I am the
Hardaway that what can be sometimes
rather awkward is if in the combined
script you have two distinct routes
through it for two distinct purposes it
can be very difficult sometimes
disentangling those when things go wrong
as inevitably they do the pattern action
paradigm is really really good it is a
great model for certain kinds of
computation grep is a pattern action
program said as a pattern action program
yak is pattern action program flex all
of those tools have that same model
here's some patterns and you read the
input and if pattern matches do the
corresponding action so they're all
great that but there are plenty of
things that don't fall into that if you
want to make two passes over something
or if you've got to remember complicated
state doesn't work as well and what I
discovered when I write lock programs is
often rather than trying to figure out
how to keep track of state from one
liner to another on the input I read the
whole input into a giant array and then
do traditional you know indexing
computations on the array it's just
easier and again having the associative
facility in matter array that you can
index into it via strings and so on
that's another big plus as well but this
business of you having a powerful
version of what you're doing at Bell
Labs but the powers that be deciding I
supposedly I guess under very great
stress of external pressure as to
exactly what should be released with a
UNIX release to the outside world on the
usual basis from what I gather that it's
just not fair so there the computer
companies were all these bright people
producing this stuff but they
cross-subsidize from our telephone bills
we you as a research community aware of
that problem all the time we were
certainly aware of it I don't think we'd
paid a tremendous amount of attention to
it but it came up from time to time it
came up I think the reason that the arc
version where the official mechanism
didn't want to release a newer version
of lock was a perfectly legitimate
concern with standardization
you want to have something that other
people can count on its behavior
properties if you put out a new version
now you have two versions and there's
potential confusion in the market and
they weren't ready to do that so it was
a combination of trying to present a
unified version of something and then
wanting to actually own what it was that
they were putting out and supporting so
I think that one was legitimate
the cross-subsidy issue I think for
people in research basically didn't
really show up I was much more of a
legal concern and I think most of what
was going on in our particular domain
was sufficiently down in the noise that
it didn't affect us the it did probably
affect the people who were doing unix
commercially which was not the research
people but the research people started
with what had been done and sorry the
commercialization people started with
what had been done in research and then
of course added lots of things that made
it a better commercial product and they
definitely I had various times had to
worry about this cross-subsidy issue
comes back to the fact that 18 T was a
regulated public monopoly getting a
guaranteed rate of return on their
investments and so yes are you cross
subsidizing by competing using money but
other people would forced to buy your
product with yes I remember well going
to presentations about our licensing
terms for UNIX and being warned about
how careful we had to be not let
commercial usage get mixed in with our
that you get into usage and so on but um
do you think in the end that had that
not been so restrictive and owner
respond AT&T that it that the need to
develop Linux might not ever have
occurred that is an excellent question I
don't think I have an answer I certainly
got an informed or accurate answer I
think probably if there had been the
equivalent of open source at the time
really open source then perhaps there
would be less different versions of
unikz floating around and there might
not be one done by this really bright
student in finland yeah I think possibly
that would have changed the game because
I know that some of the software
development that went associated with
UNIX broadly was people trying to go
around the ATT licensing considerations
yeah because we encountered that in our
typesetting adventures that basically
the whole business of reverse
engineering jailbreak and whatever you
want to call it that you did was really
motivated by the fact that the whole
concept of openness just wasn't there in
the seventies notice you just had to
have closed system there was no way out
of it did you realize at the time how
pioneering you would be in a way about
all of this no I don't think so
certainly not on the typesetting front
where I don't think it was pioneering it
was simply trying to remove an
impediment we couldn't use the
typesetter with the software that came
with it was unusable and so necessity
again had to do something to make it so
that we can actually do what we wanted
to do because their software systems
weren't up to what we wanted to do more
broadly the openness and that you see
today in language design and operating
systems and so on I don't think we
predicted that in any way either it's
not clear how you make money doing that
and of course a lot of systems at the
time certainly in the 70s and 80s this
was the lifeblood of the companies that
provided the service and so they
couldn't just give it away and make it
back in what do you make it back in
public relations
ah now you have to make it back by
turning yourself and saying you can get
the free
version but if you want really good
backup where the people to give it but
of course that's not a stance that
companies were prepared to take in those
days again I mean as we both know it
happened with computer hardware so they
have McGarry typesetting hardware they
could not any visitor scene where they
didn't sell the hardware but little with
the software yes that certainly was the
model for a long long time and in fact
in early days the IBM days let's say in
the 60s and 70s IBM made all of their
money on on the hardware and the
software was kind of given away as part
of it yeah there's all sorts of
ramifications over the South Atlantic
about when will I be n before was to
unbundle I remember the worst pretty
clearly indeed anyway after all I get
impression that then over the next few
years you moved into other areas of
interest to be around for a while and
things like total TK which I've never
used so could you say something about
that
yeah tickled TK is it there's really two
pieces that this this is just wonderful
work by john ousterhout who at the time
was at berkeley now at Stanford and what
John did
tickle TCL the tool controlling which
was basically a an interpreted language
of a scripting language if you like that
made it very easy to extend by adding C
functions so that the essence of it was
that you could write code in this but
you would be mostly calling functions
that have been written in C as a
language it's bizarre that I've told
John that on a number of occasions but
it was very very powerful you could
actually do a lot with it and then TK
was an instance of a set of C functions
that would do something interesting and
it was basically a set of graphics
routines that worked with x11 so that
you could very easily draw things of
real complexity of richness on a screen
and I think as a graphics package it is
a great improvement of all of its
successors it's just a remarkably
efficient effective and rich environment
so I used that for a number of years
doing quick and dirty user interfaces
for a variety of things and even one
that was used for a while inside Bell
Labs there was a project ill-conceived
I think at least in retrospect for doing
wireless systems that would work well
inside buildings especially big
buildings like say hospitals and big
stores
and so to do that you need something
that will tell you how electromagnetic
radiation propagates within the building
so you have an elaborate model for e/m
propagation you have to know where
things are in the buildings where the
walls what are they made of what are the
floors all of that kind of thing and
then from that you can say if I put base
station equipment routers if you're like
in various places the building then I
can figure out what the coverage in the
building is but that's all kind of
low-level radio sort of thing how do you
make that accessible to somebody who
might be you know an engineer trying to
design this stuff or somebody with not
any of the real radio background and so
what we did was to design a system that
had all of that prediction of
propagation the models and on top of
that a user interface which would show
you slices through the building show you
where the walls were and things like
that and say if you put base station
there this is what the propagation is
going to look like over the building and
then in addition we could even optimize
that so that it would tell you this is
where you want to put the base stations
given the number you proposed to do and
I wrote that user interface that was
that was my part of it I wrote that user
interface in tickle TK and it was really
really effective and surprisingly easy I
remember being on a conference call with
some people who were the ultimate users
intended users of the system and they
said you know we really need a feature
to do something I don't remember what
the feature was and they kept talking
about the feature during the conference
call and while they were doing it I was
sitting in my office I implemented it in
TK because it was just so easy it's
really really great so this was your
translation into the world
graphics terms in a way because early in
those days yeah because we finally had
terminals that were just text exactly
and I think one of the things that was
of interest great interest was you could
see the huge strength of Unix in the
days of dumb terminals if you like but
how was it going to cope with the great
graphics onslaught in the late eighties
now I've been looking back on it were
all sorts of internal projects on your
own terminals and so on were they not
yeah we had we had weird terminals the
the one that I remember most clearly was
the Tektronix 40:14 some random number I
can't remember there's lots of random
numbers in computing but it was tech a
big thing big green green screen and um
but it had a sort of vector graphics
kind of thing where he could draw lines
you couldn't do much beyond that no
shading or anything and so there was
some graphics done with that and then
eventually we started to get color
terminals that were bitmap not vector aw
and so there was a lot of interest in
software to drive those sorts of things
I didn't do very much of that by that
point I was using other people's
libraries because that's a fairly
specialized technical area to do that
well but in that sense that was really
where collaboration outside of Bell Labs
had to come in for things like X windows
yes so to become a standard yeah yeah so
we reasonably cool about as what Bell
Labs you didn't feel that you ought to
be totally dominating this field I don't
think I didn't care in the slightest um
there were people around me who I think
thought that X was very big very
complicated and perhaps unnecessarily so
I know that Rob pipe in particular did
some really good work with overlapping
bitmap graphics so that if you have you
know two windows on the screen and you
do something with them that you get a
very efficient rapid update and he did
some of the very first work on that very
efficient algorithms that I guess he
eventually found their way into X and so
there were people interested in a bit
blit the technical thing for bit mapping
and but I had drifted out
that at that point and so I didn't pay
much attention to it I think I've hold a
lot of questioning for far too long
Brian
so actually cameraman Shawn the computer
file people will know he is expert at
shouting questions as well as doing the
filming so over to usual we took his
reference manual which is a really
excellent reference manual as a big
piece of it took that verbatim and then
we feel job for a couple of summers and
that paid off both in future context but
also given something to do for my thesis
which I think Brian probably muttered
under his breath what you don't know is
I've got a secret weapon